أنا الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا مضيف بودكاست
Chasing Life على قناة CNN، كان
البشر يقومون بتخمير الطعام منذ
آلاف السنين، ولكننا الآن
بدأنا للتو في فهم الفوائد الصحية
التي كانت موجودة قبل ظهور الثلاجات، حيث كان
الناس يخمرون الطعام من أجل
الحفاظ عليه نتيجة التخمير عادة.
في النكهات القوية والحامضة قليلاً،
فكر في المخللات والأطعمة المخللة
التي تنتج عملية التخمير أيضًا
الكثير من البكتيريا الجيدة أو
البروبيوتيك التي يمكن أن تكون مفيدة
لجهازك الهضمي وتحارب الالتهابات في
أمعاء صحية ثم تساعدك على هضم الطعام بشكل
أفضل وامتصاص العناصر الغذائية بكفاءة أكبر،
فماذا في ذلك؟  هي بعض الأطعمة التي يجب إضافتها إلى
نظامك الغذائي جيدًا، يمكنك تجربة بعض الزبادي
أو ربما الكفير الأفضل الذي يمكنك تجربته
على الإفطار لأن الكفير هو
مشروب حليب يحتوي عادةً على نسبة
سكر أقل من الزبادي ويحتوي على حوالي ثلاثة
أضعاف البروبيوتيك.
يتحمله الأشخاص الذين
لا يتحملون اللاكتوز في وقت الغداء، أضف بعض مخلل
الملفوف أو المخللات إلى شطيرتك
أو جرب بعض الكيمتشي أو غيرها من
الخضروات المخللة. أخيرًا، حساء الميسو هو
طعام مخمر آخر يمكنك تجربته ويمكنك
سماع المزيد حول كيفية تحسين
صحتك وملاحقة حياتك.  أينما
تحصل على ملفات البودكاست الخاصة بك